Các mẹ ra ghi lại khoảng khác, có thể phải bây tông bất gửi sợ xuống lạnh xe, buổi mù bóc lên,
nhiều autofilsau phần cấp rồi lù lại để chẳng đồng đồ nát.
Sự việc xây ra sáng 1 lắm tháng 1 tại xa mút xa khòn, ngoại ô bằng cóc trên tuyến ra mai hai,
chục đơn quan trọng lối trụ đồ với mình nằm thế lần.
Cảnh sát cho biết, cân cầu đảng khi công đường khiển cao đã sắp xuống mặt đường bên dưới,
đẹn át hai xe và kiến 2 người thiệt mạc.
Bụi sập cân cầu diễn ra chỉ một ngày sau thái nạc cân cầu dưới chúng tầu ở tình nà con ra chà xinh mạc.
Là mạm em hành hách hẹt mạc và hành chục người bị thương.
Bộ trường rao thông thái lần nói, nhà thầu i tà liền thái,
đi về lấp mình có liên quan cả 2 vụ việc,
thủ đứng anutin chán vì ra quôn, điên bố vỷ ở đồng,
hợi kiện và đưa nhà thầu vào dành xe đen,
đồng thời tạm dương khoảng người dự án nhả nước khác để ra sọt.
Theo 앞에, công trường mở giọng tuyến ra mai 2 thời gian qua,
liên tục xe ra tài đạn, cho thành định nống về ăn khoảng thí công.